now can you start a channel before you
have an audience what can you talk about
having channel and not really having an
audience broadcasting videos too given
this yeah yeah absolutely you don't need
an audience you seen a message you had a
message you need just like when you
start a business you know you don't have
customers yet but you need to have
something to sell yeah right so you
don't need to have an audience anywhere
else but you need to have something to
say right you need to be able to put
your art out there whether it's given
advice or giving motivation or showing
people how to make something you have to
have some kind of expertise you will
give value to the new audience that will
be coming in so if your business coach
you know you've been coaching businesses
great you know what are the common
lessons that you have to give people the
common problems that you see people
coming in with consistently that you can
then create video content to help it's
slower if you don't have an audience
anywhere else just like any other
business if you don't have customers
it's slower to launch a new product but
that shouldn't this shouldn't hold you
back from from starting it up